he let the Japanese video game company  Nintendo through years of growth  now nintendo president Satoru Iwata is  dead at the age of 55 starting in 2002  Avada transformed Nintendo into a global  company introducing the popularity as  portable game machine only a few years  later Nintendo presentable would become  its flagship product the Wii video game  console equipped with a brand new  controller device the console boosted  company sales by 70% but in recent years  Nintendo has been struggling with  slumping sales as owada  focused on the company's existing  portfolio instead of pursuing new  developments most of all the booming  mobile gaming segment nevertheless the  now-deceased owada was regarded as a  revolutionary who was leaving a void in  the gaming industry or is one fan put it  he didn't just create technology he  created a whole culture